okay let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 starting with our caller from
the 4-1 to area code caller from four
one two tell me who you are where you
come from does this mean that is you is
Zack recently became a member about a
month ago
oh thanks Zack and I was wondering in
regards to Donald Trump's mental health
yeah if a licensed psychiatrist were to
sit down like personally with him
evaluate him and then diagnose him with
some disorder do you think that that
would affect his base in any way or
anything in the election 2020 nope they
basically say dr. Ronnie Jackson said
he's great because he could identify a
llama on a piece of paper and tell you
what time it was and where he was and
psychiatry is they'll say it's
pseudoscience or something you know I
mean I think at this point there is like
a 32 to 35 percent immutable base of
support for Donald Trump so he might
lose you know 5 to 7 percentage points
of support if someone were to say this
is a man who is cognitively here's a
formal diagnosis he is not well I I
think that it's it's not going to affect
a lot of people in his base they just
won't believe it
ok and the second question do you think
that in the future there should be some
sort of test like you'd have to undergo
some evaluation by psychiatrists for
future elections listen I like the idea
in terms of what it would do and what
the objective would be I think that
anytime we add restrictions for either
voting or being elected we want to be
just like a hundred and ten percent sure
that these are not additional
restrictions that would have some
unintended consequence of limiting who
can participate in the political system
being president is I mean it's such a
major thing that it's not unreasonable
to put more restrictions on it but I
would want to be really sure that it's
being done in a way that couldn't have
some one intended consequence but it you
know I would be fine saying you've got
to release your tax return
and along those lines it doesn't strike
me as crazy to say that you should
undergo some kind of psychiatric
evaluation a really a thorough one that
being said not just point to the tiger
right okay thank you all right
appreciate the call thank you so much